(audience applauding)
(slow pop music)
♪ When I'm away from you ♪
♪ I'm happier than ever ♪
♪ Wish I could explain it better ♪
♪ I wish it wasn't true ♪
♪ I don't relate to you, ooh ♪
♪ I don't relate to you, no ♪
♪ 'Cause I'd never treat me this ♪
♪ I hate that you hate this city ♪
♪ And I don't talk about
you on the internet ♪
♪ Never told anyone anything bad ♪
♪ 'Cause that's just embarrassing,
you were my everything ♪
♪ And all that you did
was make me feel sad ♪
♪ So don't waste the time I don't have ♪
♪ And don't try to make me feel bad ♪
♪ I could talk about every time
that you showed up, but I ♪
♪ Well, I'd have an empty
line 'cause you never did ♪
♪ Never paid any mind to my
mother or friends, so I ♪
♪ Shut 'em all out for
you just like a kid ♪
♪ You ruined everything good ♪
♪ Always said you were misunderstood ♪
♪ Made all my moments your own ♪
♪ Just leave me alone ♪
(audience clapping)
(audience cheering)